let's get right to albert breer our
friend from sports illustrated in the
mmqb right here on the rich eisen show
albert i appreciate the time greatly i'm
sure your phone's buzzing like crazy
thanks for the call appreciate it
no you always you know that okay
appreciate it let's get right into it um
the von miller trade
i love it that's the only way to put it
i love it i love the aggressivity
for the rams to just keep on getting
more and more pot committed uh what can
you tell us about it albert
yeah you know i i think what's
interesting you know they've always been
aggressive but i i think over the last
couple of years
um what you've noticed is that
they are really kind of
putting all of their wreaths
into you know what they consider value
positions right like and so you know
before where i think you know if they
were just aggressive and trying to stock
good players now they've really focused
it on a few spots and you know it's it's
receivers it's quarterbacks it's corners
and it's pass rushers and you know we
saw what they did with stafford we saw
it with ramsey
and you know vaughn's a little different
because bond doesn't have as much time
left
um as as ramsay did when they traded for
hammer as stafford does now um that
they've traded for him even though he's
a little older obviously there's a
position difference there
um no but they've really kind of had a
focus on
um you know trying to put as much as
they can and what they consider premium
positions and clearly
you know von miller was the best team on
a super bowl champion six years ago now
is he the player that he was back then
probably not but you know now he's gonna
be playing alongside aaron donald
alongside leonard floyd he won't need to
do quite as much so
uh yeah i mean i think it's an awfully
aggressive move um and you know i i
think it kind of is along the lines of
what they've done the last two or three
years so they focus that on premium
positions
you know and i think for denver
i mean man if you're vic angio you don't
feel great about this no
this is i mean if you're vic fangio
you're saying okay like now we're
starting to under a new general manager
under a first year general manager
george beyton we're starting to
look towards 2022 and what does that
mean for my future um you know so it's
interesting from the rams perspective of
course they're all in and i think a
seven in one start certainly you know
confirms the way that they felt about
themselves
going into the season
you know and the broncos of course start
3-0 but the whole thing's kind of come
undone on them since then and that's why
um you know that's why i think they're
sort of turning their focus towards 2022
when you know who knows maybe they're
the ones that are going big game hunting
for a quarterback well i mean look i i i
they have to i mean that's that's for
sure and
to see von miller go
right and they get the draft capital
it's it strikes me as a maneuver
that would be would count against them
account against them and aaron rodgers
saying i'll go there right i mean you're
trading away championship pieces unless
what you get him back unless you sign
him back you get the picks and you kind
of pull like what the yankees did
whether all this chapman and the cubs
back in the day
well look at it this way right so you
got bradley up so they're gonna have to
pay him
um von miller i believe is
is
i i have to look this up because i you
know it's a lot happening once i think
he's in the contract here so maybe you
had the idea
he's not coming back right and maybe
because you know more about him than
anybody else you're thinking to himself
this isn't going to be the same player
in 2022.
so
let's get what we can now we'll build
more quarterback build more capital go
get a quarterback and then say they do
what the rams did right which the rams
had matthew stafford in place at the end
of january last year
now you've cleared spots and you've got
all this draft capital and if you go and
trade for an aaron rodgers or russell
wilson
or or deshaun watson at that point
now you can say well look we're trading
for you and then on top of that
we've got more capital and more space to
build around you with guys that are
going to be here for the next few years
rather than having von miller on the
roster and oh by the way
you know now maybe we have the space to
go take care of bradley chubb who's
going to be our new kind of
you know war horse pastor
so you know i think it's sort of a chess
move by george payton and that it's
we're going to have assets and we're
going to have space to build in 2022 and
not only can we bring in a quarterback
but on top of that we're going to have
the resources to build aggressively
around that quarterback with a guy who's
probably going to be here a lot a little
longer than von miller would have been
now we're here on the rich eisen show uh
what's going on with desean watson as
you and i are sitting here at six
minutes after one eastern time
uh the day before the deadline trade
what what do you tell me i i mean
honestly rich like i
you know i i don't think this thing was
ever that close and things can happen
fast so
um but i felt for the last couple of
weeks that this was really 50 50 and um
you know to me there are really three
people um who are sort of helping to
control this process one's desean watson
clearly he wants out there
cal mayor he wants deshaun watson out of
town um and then three is nick casario
who is sort of the
i would say the
least emotionally attached party in this
whole thing right like and he's the one
who is sort of
the caretaker of what the next five to
10 years of the houston texas look like
and
i i think nick has been you know
i just think very reasoned about this
whole thing and thinking
i'm not going to give away most valuable
asset the asset like what happens with
deshaun watson
will in all likelihood go a long way
towards painting
how his tenure as a general manager
looks at houston over the next five ten
years however long he's there and so
if you're nick you know you can't afford
to to go get 50 cents on a dollar for
him and if it means waiting until
february or march for there to be more
clarity legally for there to be more
clarity from the league um and for there
to be more suitors right because you
think at that point who knows you know
maybe the browns are involved we know
the four teams that have been monitoring
it are the panthers the dolphins the
broncos and the eagles well you know
maybe we get to to march and april maybe
the you know maybe the browns are
involved maybe the seahawks are involved
in the giants involved and so you could
have a much better market then and oh by
the way
what do we lose by waiting until then i
mean if you wait until then i like i
guess the downside would be he's in your
building but you've already i would
argue weathered the storm when it comes
to that because he's been in the
building for three months without
playing
um and any picks that you get back you
can't use till april anyway
so you know i think nick cassario's
[ __ ] right is that
um you know he's just sort of saying to
other teams
and i guess the bet would be the legal
situation's not going to get worse um
that would be the one area where there's
some risk but
you know if you're nicosia now i think
the best thing to do is to wait for the
the market to sort of rebound for desean
watson and i think there's a better
chance that happening by waiting
um then by just you know doing something
out of panic right now unless
you know again somebody on the other
side of the table panics and and offers
full price for them all right now uh
obviously seattle gets thrown in there
if russ and they divorce and
you know other teams
browns that's a new one for me i'll be
honest and i know that they've got to
make a decision on baker mayfield and
dak money would be something um that
even i somebody who's been caping for
for baker would have an issue
uh paying him like literally if that's
the sort of stance he's taken with the
cleveland browns in some you know in a
long-term conversation
uh i'd be like you know uh
we need to we need to reconfigure our
relationship is that possible are you
serious that the browns would is that
what i mean just think about it this way
okay like i
what was the b level quarterback
contract i mean it just it just never
really exists all right it's just
like like if you look at the
quarterbacks there's like the franchise
type quarterbacks who are all making who
were all at one point like right at the
top of the market right at one point it
was 30 then it was 35 and now it's in
the 40s right so there's that category
quarterback and there's like this
precipitous fall so like guys making
like eight nine ten million dollars a
year you know what i mean so there's no
real
like b level quarterback contract and so
you know i i think that's sort of how
you know over the years it's evolved
where it's either a yes or no question
right like either you think that's a
franchise guy or you don't
and you know like when teams have sort
of dragged it out in the past
uh like the the buccaneers did with
famous winston like the like the the
titans
i did with marcus mariota almost
uniformly at least divorce you know so
i think that's sort of where the browns
and baker are now where the browns have
to answer that yes or no question
and i think they go one or two ways like
i think they either go
all in and baker gets into the playoffs
and they're all right we're gonna pay
him and maybe it's not what you know
josh allen got but it's in that
neighborhood
or
they do what the rams or the niners did
last year where they look at their
quarterback and they say it's a really
good but we need to be better if we're
going to pay full price for a franchise
quarter
we do it with a guy that we think is
elite and um you know it's a
conversation again the deniers had last
year um in january in february it's the
conversation the rams had in january
where those teams looked at it and those
teams remember those teams both the
niners and the rams both had
quarterbacks in their 20s who had taken
them to the super bowl who had multiple
years left on their contract and they
moved off of those guys because they
didn't think it was good enough and so i
think either the browns decide to pay
baker
um you know with a full franchise level
contract
or you know i think this thing is maybe
hurtling towards
where you know the rams and the niners
were with gotham and uh garoppolo a year
ago
albert breer a few more minutes left
with the senior nfl reporter the mmqb of
sports illustrated here on the rich
eisen show as we're talking right now
mike vrabel is announcing to the media
that derek henry will indeed have
surgery on his broken foot
suffered in uh the season um in my mind
uh afc south sealing win for the titans
uh in week eight net no timetable for
his return what do you think
their next step is figuratively with
their guy on the shelf their best player
on the shelf what do you got for me
it's hard i mean i i think they you know
um you know i think our my old colleague
your colleague at nfl now i think ian
reported that um
you know they're gonna kick the tires on
adrian peterson and i would think
they're gonna
you know look at some guys and there are
some players that have been you know
sort of shopped around for trade
uh you certainly could call seattle
about something like rashad penny um you
know marlon mack you know who's falling
behind jonathan taylor obviously
in the pecking order um in indianapolis
should be another name that's been
floating around there for the last
couple of weeks
um but there's no replacing derrick
henry you know what i mean like it's
just
i
i mean correct me if i'm wrong i i can't
think of a quarter but i can't think of
a non-quarterback who is more to his
team than derek henry means to the
titans well camaron camaro might be the
only guy that uh approaches that um that
that level but i i i hear you that that
is just an
absolute crusher uh of an injury there's
really not much more to say other than
other than the fact that that is an mvp
candidate that just right and here's how
if you think about this too like the
other part of it is like now um
ryan tannel has to make his money right
like you paid brian can help 33 million
dollars a year ryan tannehill has to
make his money um you know
like aj brown um you know like let's see
if you're a number one receiver now
they're gonna have to pay him let's see
let's see you know what you've got uh
you know obviously julio jones they
trade for him in the off season can he
um raise his level play the defense like
and the defense maligned over the last
couple of years but it's made some big
plays the last couple of weeks we've
seen it with kevin bayer
um they're making huge plays against the
chiefs and then yesterday against the
colts so
um you know i know one thing about that
team like
you know for the all the flaws and
they've had flaws um because mike brabo
has gotten there that is a tough team
it's a resilient team
um and you know they really play with
identity and that's going to be the
question to me is like when your
identity has been so centered on one guy
and you know the tough rugged tennessee
titans like derek henry embodied that
um can you do that by committee i think
that's really going to be the question
going forward because i i don't doubt
the resilience of that group we've seen
the last few years
but you know this is the sort of blow
that sort of i think
kind of gets back to you know gets back
to chipping away at the identity of who
they've been
and then lastly for you albert breer um
what is the saints plan do you think
with jameis being out did they stick
with trevor simeon who looked terrific
um in just
the first blush middle of the game
adrenaline rushing
um
you know role but you know week in week
out and this is that saints team if they
beat the falcons this week they're in
first place because the the bucks are on
a bye week they have the same record and
obviously they've already beaten tampa
so
that's i mean this is this is huge
taysom hill has been in concussion
protocol do they go with him do they
actually pick up a free agent like cam
newton would that be
something that they'd be into because
that might actually pick up the phone i
don't know they've been aggressive like
the rams the last few years do they pick
up the phone and call houston you know
what i mean like if you really want to
get wild with it maybe you do something
like that or um you know i i mean you
know like call true breed he's called
philip
uh i think this is going to be
interesting because i i think one thing
that sean payton has gotten enough
credit for
is how he sort of managed the
you know the kind of the twilight of
drew brees's career and how they built a
team around drew brees that i think was
rock solid and they didn't get enough
credit for that
but if you look at it you know over the
last three years 19 20 and 21
sean payton and the saints are 13 and 3
without drew brees as a quarterback
which is an amazing number right and so
i think absent going and bringing
somebody and i do think that they're
going to explore bringing somebody else
in
um you know i was talking to a couple of
guys last night
and i i don't
i wouldn't rule anything out i think
that there's a possibility it's going to
sound crazy that we see like almost like
a quarterback shuttle with simeon and
taysom hill when he comes back from his
concussion both having roles
um and i know that sort of sounds
anaesthetical to the way that nfl
philosophy has been forever and ever but
if there's someone who's willing to buck
that trend
and go with like a quarterback shuttle
and do something creative um because you
know they're lacking a little bit of the
receiver position and they need to do
things that create like an offensive
threat i think sean payton's that guy
right like so
um you know i think they will kick tires
on guys on the outside and they will
take a look at guys on the outside
um you know but i wouldn't be surprised
if you know if if they do decide to
stick with the guys in the roster if we
see just sort of a creative sort of
platoon
where you know taysom hills got a big
role but it's more of like a i guess
sort of a slash like cordell stewart
back in the day role with trevor simeon
having his own role as well well i mean
i mean what what would mimik taysom
hill's uh playbook better than cam
newton right i mean he's sitting right
here he's that yeah right i mean he's
ready to go thank god and you know it's
interesting too because
um you know obviously like you know sean
payton was in the division with cam
newton for a long time
and
i i i you know i think if there's
anybody who would know creatively
how to
pump life into his career i mean like
look at the i mean like i just think
like that stat that i like that i gave
you right i just think it's the most
staggering thing that he's 13 and three
without drew brees the last three years
amazing how quarterback centric the
league's gotten and it's not with like
the same backup either it's with teddy
bridgevirus which jameis winston is with
jason hill like they've done it with so
many different guys
it would be fascinating to see what what
would happen if he brought cam newton in
and could find a way to pump life back
into his career because we saw him do it
with teddy bridgewater right who was
coming off of like it's just a
catastrophic injury we've seen him do it
with jameis winston
um i don't know if they're gonna do it
but it would be certainly fascinating to
see
um see what what he could do with cam
based on
how far it seemed my cam had fallen last
year yeah it's it's kind of crazy albert
um it's only been three weeks it was
three weeks ago tonight that john gruden
resigned and that feels like now three
years ago you know and um i guess that's
my last one for you
anybody check in on him yeah what's
what's his next move
based on you know the owner's meeting
you were there i'm sure you heard a lot
of chatter about it so what what what
what do you think gruden's next move is
here uh i mean like i i've talked to a
couple people around him over the last
week and
i you know the feedback i've got he's
doing okay um it's obviously devastating
you know i mean
effectively his career is over
so um you know i
i don't know whether or not he's gonna
sue the league um you know but it's
certainly it certainly felt like you
know last time i checked at least like
like all things are on the table now and
um yeah i mean i
i mean this thing's got potential to get
ugly rich because you know the the the
the leaking of those emails i mean we
have a lot of finger pointing internally
in the league and
you know that owners meeting last week
in new york roger goodell got up there
and he told the group said i can't say
for a hundred i can't say for sure what
everybody did but i can tell you for
certain like nobody that i know of
leaked those emails nobody inside 345
park
um and then later in the day tonya
snyder you know dan snyder's wife got up
and swore up and down that the snyder
family had nothing to do with leaking
those emails so
um there's certainly been a lot of
questions about how that happened and
um you know i i i i mean one way we we
might find out if somebody is if
somebody like john gruden decides that
it's time to to file a lawsuit um so
it'll be interesting to see what he does
because if he does decide to go that
route
that could wind up i guess opening a lot
of closets with some skeletons in them
over the next uh over the next few
months albert appreciate the time um
boy
everything you just said it's remarkable
uh all that's going on in the nfl so
much of it could be dated five minutes
from now that's
that's how this situation is it's
unbelievable
keep your eyes on houston we got until
four o'clock tomorrow right okay thanks
for the call albert you'd be well take
care all right thanks i'll represent
from the mmqb
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here